hey guys i'm justine welcome to fall
fashion as you know it's now fall so
it's time to get out the ugg boots the
pumpkin spice lattes and the sweaters
more importantly i'm gonna show you guys
how to do fall correctly a lot of people
really overdo it when it comes to fall
fashion i'm going to show you the
perfect outfit that you can put together
cost effective easy to do you can wear
it anywhere to school to a parade to
thanksgiving dinner whatever you want to
do however you want to wear this it's up
to you so first you guys want to go to
the craft store crafts
and i picked out some really great fall
foliage i live in los angeles so there's
not a single colorful leaf that i could
even go out and get i would recommend
using real leaves but in the case that
you don't have leaves
use fake ones they were all on sale
that's great i also picked up some
orange duct tape i don't know what i'm
gonna use this for but i'm sure i will
find a use also get yourself some
scissors at said craft store i picked up
this fabulous child's orange t-shirt
even though i've got on this orange tank
top it's just not enough you need the
t-shirt because it's chilly out okay
you're gonna need some tape and some
really pretty fall leaf stickers now the
thing with fall is usually a lot of
people are wearing clothes and they're
wearing layers but the key to wearing
layers is make sure
i don't actually really know what the
key is but uh all i know is i wanted to
cut this t-shirt so make up whatever
excuse you want i think i'm gonna do
like a nice little v-neck so just take
your scissors cut cut cut cut cut cut
into a v
i made a mistake i actually cut the back
of the t-shirt also so
we'll just see what happens don't be
stupid like me cut cut this looks great
actually i think this might work now try
your t-shirt on before you start your
fall fashion fiesta this looks great who
would have thought that would have
worked not me now that you've got your
t-shirt cut and stuff you want to break
out your duct tape now i didn't even
know the duct tape came in different
colors so this is news to me it's great
news
so let's start off by taking your
lightest color leaves and you're going
to wrap this around your waist it's very
subtle it's very subtle make sure you
cut off the tags you're going to do a
really simple move it's called a knot
you take one leaf cross them over tuck
under pull and what you've created here
is a very nice little belt
nice little strip of it make sure you've
got a nice pair of pants on not too nice
and just stick this to yourself you want
to hook this into your belt because
leaves are all connected kids circle of
life and stuff and wrap it around your
leg because it looks good now you may
notice that you might have a little
trouble here at the bottom of your leg
we've got more duct tape for that tape
it to your leg it's like an ankle
bracelet look how good this looks tell
me everything you know about fashion no
please don't because i'm telling you now
your other leg is prepped and ready oh
yeah so do the same thing on the other
side look how good that is now with this
last piece that you have fall hair
fashions are also really really
important now a lot of girls wear really
cute little headbands and they wear them
like these little like tierra things and
they're real subtle do the same thing as
you did around your waist but just do it
on your head
another thing that's really important
during fall and winter times as the
temperature drops if you're a girl you
know sometimes it gets a little cold i
have devised the perfect plan i mean
this can be for a girl for a guy because
let's face it we all have nipples some
of us have more than one if you happen
to have four nipples that's okay because
we've got four leaves for you so you
just want to strategically place these
where your nipples would be you can be
freezing cold and not a single soul
we'll be aware now if you happen to have
more than two nipples more than three
nipples you just place these right where
those extra nips would be this looks so
great so that completes our fall fashion
tutorial i hope that you guys enjoyed it
i think this is gonna be beautiful for
really anyone it'll look great on any
skin tone any hair color it's all about
confidence so if you're confident that
you can pull this look off you won't
have a problem let me know if you guys
do this wear it out send me photos post
it on instagram hashtag ijfallfashion
and i will see you soon for a very very
special fall makeup tutorial i never
seen a diamond in the flesh
cut my teeth on wedding rings
in the movies i'm not proud of my
address
and a torn up town
no postcode envy we stole maybach
diamonds on your timepiece we don't care
you